ces sanctions ont des conséquences déjà
pour les rues ce jeudi d'une golf
bonjour vous étiez à moscou pour france
24 vous étiez en russie dans un contexte
particulier pendant la guerre et pendant
la censure aussi on va en parler mais
d'abord sur ces sanctions comment est ce
qu elle pèse sur la population au
quotidien alors donc on a passé huit
jours en russie je suis entré hier soir
et on a pu voir au fur et à mesure des
jours et bien les russes commencé à
réaliser l'impact de ces sanctions parce
que bien sûr l'impact n'est pas immédiat
l'impact le plus direct qu'on a pu voir
c'est d'une part et bien les gens qui
ont commencé à avoir peur pour leurs
économies et commencer à retirer un peu
leurs économies dans les banques même si
on peut pas parler de panique bancaire
et puis d'autre part il ya un impact qui
est très visuel c'est beaucoup de grands
groupes européens ou occidentaux qui ont
décidé de se retirer de russie on pense
notamment et bien à zara à ikea est donc
le jour où il a annoncé qu'il se
retirait de russie et bien les russes se
sont rués chez cas il y avait des files
d'attentes très impressionnant des
magasins sont fermés les magasins sont
fermés et est ce que pouvaient disait à
des économistes russe sait que dans les
prochaines semaines et bien dans les
grands centres commerciaux moscovite qui
sont très très impressionnant bien 50%
des boutiques pourrait fermer ce qui
fait évidemment beaucoup réagir les gens
sur place une jeune femme assez branché
me disais mais moi j'ai envie de
continuer à avoir le choix c'est un
retour en arrière pour nous d'avoir des
produits uniques de consommation je veux
continuer à voir le jeu choix de ce que
je regarde ce que je consomme voilà donc
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
l'impression qu'ils se dirigent vers un
retour en arrière qui y font notamment
référence aux années 90 où ils faisaient
la queue dans les magasins pour obtenir
des produits de première nécessité etc
russes sont peut-être ceux qui se
mobilisent contre la guerre au moins
5000 personnes hier ont été arrêtés dans
69 villes russes c'est une ong au v des
infos qui donne cette information en
tout cas c'est inédit si c'est vrai
c'est assez inédit et on a pu voir ces
arrestations quotidienne en réalité
tous les jours des jeunes se font
arrêter je parle de jeunes parce que ce
sont eux qui bien manifeste
majoritairement faut bien comprendre que
les manifestations sont interdites en
russie donc les gens qui vont manifester
prendre un très gros risque